[Music]
on this Tuesday night investigation
confirmation the RCMP now says it's
probing possible Chinese interference in
Canada's Democratic process as the Prime
Minister gets grilled he was informed
yes or no
branching out the Royal Bank wants to
buy HSBC Canada what it could mean for
customers
Extinction warning the species in danger
in Canada we are losing nature faster
than we can recover it and whether
reversing the trend is realistic
plus two police constables joined forces
to heal military comrades in crisis it's
difficult to ask for help when you're
currently suffering the critical Mission
off the battlefield
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
is more insight tonight into a story
Global News first broke about
allegations of Chinese interference in
the 2019 federal election the head of
the RCMP now confirms the force is
investigating foreign interference
including in Canada's Democratic process
by commissioner Brenda Luckey does not
give any details because she says that
could be injurious to the conduct of
international Affairs the defense of
Canada or any state Allied or associated
with Canada the Revelation came in a
letter to a House of Commons committee
studying allegations of foreign
interference Mackenzie gray has our top
story tonight
oral questions the explosive allegations
of alleged interference in the 2019
election dominated question period today
at any time
prior to the recent media reports he was
informed by his officials of
interference by Beijing in our elections
yes or no I have never gotten any
information from any of our security
agencies or police officers or
intelligence officials or public
servants on any information on anyone
receiving as a federal candidate
receiving money uh from China as the
allegations highlighted those
allegations first reported by global
news outline a briefing the Prime
Minister receives saying ceases had
evidence China ran a sophisticated
scheme to influence the 2019 election by
finally nearly a quarter million dollars
to at least 11 different candidates and
13 different campaign staff today in a
letter to the procedure in house Affairs
committee obtained by global news RCMP
commissioner Brenda lucky said the
mounties did not have any evidence of
alleged interference during the 2019
campaign but are now probing
interference in Democratic processes
lucky adding the RCMP can confirm that
it currently does have investigations
into broader foreign actor interference
activities these investigations are
ongoing the confirmation of RCMP
investigations comes just days after
liberals announced their new
indo-pacific strategy with the goal of
trying to isolate China and improve ties
with friendly nations in the region
yesterday the Chinese Ambassador was set
to give his response to the liberal plan
during a speech at the University of
Ottawa but just before the speech
started multiple media organizations
were told by the university that they
couldn't film the ambassador's remarks
in a statement to Global News the
university put the blame on the Chinese
saying the ambassador's unexpected
refusal to allow cameras jeopardize the
event which frustrated activists who
hoped to be in the room if the
university wants to keep it is
neutrality then we should expect them to
provide the same opportunity in the same
spot to ask questions from that the
person and that opportunity is denied
not only for us but the Canadian media
as well the confirmation of the RCMP
investigations was just a small part of
the letter Brenda like he sent to the
house Affairs committee the rest of it
explaining why the mounties won't
produce any documents related to Chinese
interference saying would impact the
Integrity of ongoing investigations
Donna all right Mackenzie gray and
Ottawa thanks prime minister Justin
Trudeau was asked today about the
Nationwide protests in China over that
country's zero coveted strategy
obviously everyone in China should be
allowed to express themselves should be
allowed to share their their
perspectives and indeed protests we're
going to continue to ensure that China
knows we'll stand up for human rights
there is now a heavy police presence on
the streets of China's major cities
after the Nationwide protests on the
weekend though Chinese authorities are
beginning to relax some of the strict
pandemic restrictions the streets of
several cities including Beijing were
largely empty of people except for
police and police cars authorities are
looking to question some protesters who
are angry about three years of strict
lockdowns and the dictatorship of the
Communist Party Health officials are now
allowing delivery services and flights
to resume in some parts of the country
people in other cities have been told
they no longer need a covid test if
they're staying home but daily mass
testing will still take place in Beijing
and other large cities
Canada's biggest bank wants to get even
bigger Royal Bank has agreed to buy the
Canadian arm of the multinational Bank
HSBC and it's prepared to spend 13.5
billion dollars to do it the transaction
still needs approval if it gets the
green light it would Mark the biggest
banking merger in Canadian history and
give even more power to one of the major
players in an already Consolidated
industry and gaviola is following this
for us tonight and what does this mean
for Canadian Bank customers
anyway you slice it Donna this deal
means less choices in a statement today
the NDP framed it as more profit for
huge Banks less options for everyday
Canadians already struggling with
inflation and higher interest costs but
given the relatively small footprint of
HSBC here in Canada the impact really
depends on where you live and how you
Bank the nation's largest bank is poised
to get even bigger by acquiring Canada's
seventh largest bank further
concentration in this oligopoly where
the big six control 95 percent of Bank
assets but hsbc's share of Canada's
banking Market is Tiny just two percent
it's a whale and and a minnow you know
it's David and his Goliath yes the
industry will become slightly more
concentrated CEO Dave Mackay says this
acquisition positions RBC as the bank of
choice for commercial clients with
International needs newcomers to Canada
and affluent clients who need global
banking and wealth management the deal
will be scrutinized by the office of the
superintendent to financial institutions
known as osfi but the Ministry of
Finance gets the final say it will
examine the impact on the rights and
interests of consumers and business
customers and it has the authority to
impose terms and conditions in terms of
for people that were looking for an
alternative to the big six Banks it does
reduce the the opportunities and options
out there several analysts tell Global
News the deal is likely to go ahead I
think it's going to be seen as a good
thing in Ottawa by the decision makers
by the Minister of Finance that these
foreign held assets of a bank in Canada
are going to become patrioted if you
will
um uh almost renationalized if I can put
it that way because they'll be under
Canadian ownership HSBC is headquartered
in London but was founded in Hong Kong
it has struggled to navigate political
pressure from the west and Beijing
following its Crackdown in Hong Kong
it's also under pressure from key
Chinese investors to focus on Asia last
year it announced plans to pull out of
the U.S and France the Finance Minister
is going to have to consider a variety
of things including the impact on
Banking and confidence in the Canadian
banking system and its stability as well
as the shifting geopolitical landscape
Donna all right angaviola in Toronto
thanks it is a big day for Alberta
Premier Danielle Smith the throne speech
delivered by the lieutenant governor has
spelled out Smith's promised Alberta
sovereignty Act
this government will no longer sit idly
by as Ottawa infringes on our
constitutional rights
Smith has already watered down her plan
setting aside her pledge to encode
rights for the unvaccinated in the Human
Rights Act she's also revealed she and
her ministers have personally called
organizations she has heard require
vaccinations Smith took over as leader
of the UCP from Jason Kenney who today
resigned as an MLA as Heather urich's
West reports Smith has yet to face
voters in an election and today's speech
from the throne is being seen as almost
the start of her campaign
a new session in Alberta's legislature
and all eyes are on Danielle Smith as
promised Smith's first order of business
is the Alberta sovereignty act the
government's promise to fight back
against Ottawa this act is to be used as
a constitutional shield to protect the
personal and provincial rights of
albertans from any unconstitutional or
harmful acts by the federal government
taken against our Province but the bill
presented to the Alberta legislature
doesn't go as far as what Smith promised
during her leadership campaign Alberta's
sovereignty act will fully respect
Canada's Constitution and the courts and
won't compel any private citizens or
businesses to violate federal law
there's an expectation that we're going
to work together that we're going to
find common ground and that we're not
going to play games that divide us the
government says it will also prioritize
Health Care affordability and the
economy but Alberta's business Community
already has concerns any measure of
uncertainty when you compete for labor
and capital with jurisdictions around
the world is not going to help Alberta
in terms of how its economically
positioned those concerns stem from both
the sovereignty act and an item
noticeably absent from Alberta's Throne
speech there will be no legislation to
protect the unvaccinated this session
though the premier says Alberta
businesses with vaccine requirements put
future provincial funds at risk if there
is still discrimination I'd like to know
about it because and people should
contact their mlas because we want to
make sure that we're creating an
environment where no one is
discriminated against Alberta is just
six months from its next provincial
election by all accounts The Campaign on
all sides is well underway and the
ruling UCP has a lot on the line in her
first couple of months in office the
polls have not demonstrated a lot of
support for Smith I think that this is
going to be quite a difficult session
for the UCP it's why affordability jobs
and the economy feature heavily in this
Throne speech as the government kicks
off this session with a new premier and
a lot to prove Heather urich's West
Global News Calgary
NATO foreign ministers meeting in
Bucharest have agreed to step up urgent
support for Ukraine that includes air
defense systems ammunition and winter
Aid NATO Secretary General Yen
stoltenberg says the alliance will also
help repair energy infrastructure
heavily damaged by Russian missile
attacks President Putin is trying to
weaponize Winter
to force ukrainians to freeze or flee
Russia acknowledges attacking Ukraine's
power grid but denies deliberately
targeting civilians NATO members
including Canada say they will stand by
Ukraine as long as it takes and will not
back down NATO also renewed a promise
made in 2008 that Ukraine will one day
be part of the world's largest security
Alliance
sounding the alarm about species under
threat coming up what's in danger of
disappearing in Canada plus it's not
Double Trouble yet the two volcanoes
erupting in Hawaii
two neighboring volcanoes are now
erupting on Hawaii's Big Island Mauna
Loa the world's largest active volcano
became active again on Sunday for the
first time since 1984. Fountains of lava
are now shooting 80 meters into the air
and less than 34 kilometers away is
Kilauea also very active it's been
erupting for more than a year now it is
rare for them both to do this at the
same time
here in Canada more than 2 000 plants
animals fish and other Wildlife are at
high risk of becoming extinct the
findings come from an extensive new
report looking into over 50 000 species
identified in this country Marnie blunt
breaks down the findings and the common
threat licking some of the species that
are disappearing
the Direct effects of climate change
growing more and more apparent
but the broader impact is less visible
and it's wiping some species off the
face of the planet Extinction is a very
chilling word once something is gone
it is gone forever
a new report from the federal and
provincial governments shows that 20
percent of species in Canada are at some
level of risk of Extinction increasing
significantly between 2010 and 2020. the
report lays bare some brutal truths in
Canada we are losing nature faster than
we can recover it
the report indicated 135 species that
are presumed to be wiped out including
the greater prairie chicken and the
black-footed ferret seven of those
species are likely endemic to Canada
meaning they're probably extinct
globally including types of vascular
plants macro fungi beetles moths and
butterflies a cause for concern among
experts it's troubling for sure it's not
a surprise a fraction of the species
that we're likely to lose within Canada
aren't anywhere else in the world and so
that's especially alarming
habitat loss agriculture urbanization
and climate change all playing a role it
has many conservation groups calling on
governments to step up
Ottawa says it's committed to halting
and reversing nature loss by 2030 and
achieving a full recovery by 2050. Chan
says it's a tall order but one that is
achievable
what we need is transformative change
the extension crisis is not separate
from the climate crisis and what we need
to do is to address those two together
the report comes ahead of next week's
comp 15 meeting in Montreal where global
leaders will be meeting to negotiate a
new Global framework for biodiversity
Donna Marnie Blanton Ottawa thank you a
guilty plea from a lawyer linked to
disgraced fashion designer Peter Nygaard
ahead what's triggered calls for a
public inquiry
a Winnipeg lawyer for disgraced fashion
designer Peter Nygaard has pleaded
guilty to professional misconduct it
relates to comments J prober made about
women and girls who have accused Nygaard
of sexual assault his guilty plea has
led to Cults to reopen the investigation
and launch a public inquiry as Melissa
region explains there are questions over
why despite numerous accusers Nygaard
has evaded charges in Winnipeg the city
where he built his business
if you can't bring a single charge
forward in this case
then what the hell is the state of the
union with the whole justice system for
Winnipeg it's non-existent
that's one of Peter nygaard's estranged
Sons he joined accusers in a virtual
press conference yesterday demanding the
Manitoba government call an inquiry into
why despite 20 complaints here Winnipeg
Police and prosecutors won't charge his
dad with sex offenses dating back to the
1980s women and girls who reported being
abused by Nygaard say his lawyer Jay
prober went on a seek and destroy
mission in the media to discredit them
they say it prevented others from coming
forward with abuse poker admitted he
failed to be courteous and civil and was
fined four thousand dollars for it but
accusers and Advocates say more needs to
happen I look forward to the day when
victims of sexual and gender-based
violence no longer have to be brave to
bring charges it should be handled like
any other violent crime if we had been
assaulted we would have been treated
differently and better Manitoba liberal
leader dougold Lamont says the case
should be investigated by somebody other
than the Winnipeg Police Service and
then re-examined by new prosecutors in
question period yesterday Deputy Premier
Cliff Cullen said Manitoba is not
getting involved as the wheels of
Justice are turning elsewhere but that
is in fact not true it is over a year
since all eight of the Winnipeg
survivors who had their cases brought
forward by Winnipeg Police there were
more than 20 who gave statements they
were all denied charges over a year ago
there is no more Justice process
happening for anyone any victim or
Survivor of Peter Nygaard in Winnipeg or
anywhere in Manitoba nyard is facing
charges of sexually abusing and
trafficking dozens of women and girls in
Toronto New York and the Bahamas he's
been denied bail and remains in custody
pending an extradition hearing to the
U.S Melissa Ridge in Global News
Winnipeg
there are countless stories of people
risking everything to flee their country
and this one image from Spain's Coast
Guard says far more about desperation
than any words can convey these three
men from Nigeria were spotted on the
rudder of an oil tanker they survived 11
days at Sea as the ship sailed from
Nigeria to the Canary Islands all three
needed to be treated for hypothermia and
dehydration according to the Red Cross
more than twenty thousand refugees
attempted to cross from West Africa to
Europe last year and it's believed more
than one thousand died along the Route
veterans helping veterans next how-to
ex-military members are supporting
comrades off the battlefield
many veterans have encountered and
endured Unthinkable events while
deployed and because of that they come
home with psychological scars that
simmer beneath the surface for years now
a new program has been designed for
police officers to help military
veterans in crisis it was created by
Veterans for veterans and as our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson reports
it's giving those who served and
sacrificed the help they deserve
on the battlefield The Perils of War are
often in plain sight but the trauma of
those experiences can linger long after
troops make it home we lost 14 on our
tour
but I lost I lost several more when I
came home
and uh I don't I don't know what's more
tragic after deploying to Afghanistan
courses in 2009 Jeremy Burns says he
came back to Canada a different person
struggling to fit into the society he
fought to defend being hyper Vigilant in
a war zone is fantastic but if I'm
switched on and Hyper Vigilant all the
time at home that's exhausting and
that's that really sets you apart from
everybody else Burns found kinship with
fellow veteran Aaron Dale meeting in
2018 when both signed up to join the
Toronto Police Service Dale served in
the Canadian Special Operations regiment
an elite unit that deploys around the
world it's highly skilled and tight-knit
leaving proved harder than expected had
a lot of confusion and a lot of
uncertainty Dale credits burns with
helping him cope with the loss of
identity he felt and encouraging him to
seek help there's a lot of help out
there but it's difficult to navigate and
it's difficult to ask for help and it's
difficult to do that when you're
suffering as a person the two veterans
realized their struggle was not unique
as the they encountered other veterans
in crisis while on the job men and women
who had served now on the other end of a
9-1-1 call
one of those veterans was Garrett Oliver
who was homeless and living in his truck
when he first met Dale in the middle of
a mental health crisis having a police
officer who was a veteran who knew which
resources could help beyond the
immediate crisis was invaluable in
turning Oliver's life around he was able
to guide me to the down a path that I
needed to go to in order to fix my
circumstance and my life
um
I owe him and Jeremy the world
for what they did for me
experiences like that led the two police
officers to create the military veterans
wellness program for police officers to
help veterans in crisis launched earlier
this summer the program is now available
to Police Services across the country
it aims to train officers on how to
interact with veterans mindful of both
their military training and the
potential experience of severe trauma
Burns and Dale enlisted an expert
psychologist and forensic psychiatrist
to develop the program combining
clinical expertise with their first-hand
experience as veterans the program also
provides a simple referral form officers
can use to connect veterans with the
specialized services and programs that
they're entitled to receive services and
programs that can be difficult to access
or even know about no matter what
struggle it is that they're struggling
with there is something available to
help them we just have to get to a point
where we're all comfortable asking for
that help Byrne says he hopes the
program will help those who have served
their country so selflessly to now get
the help they need and deserve Mercedes
Stevenson Global News
Ottawa
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is the Japanese garden at Hatley
Park in call Wood British Columbia we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to us and thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow bye-bye
thank you
foreign
[Music]